you don't have Thursday night football
it'll be on the NFL Network it's Chiefs
Raiders you have the Dolphins in the jet
yeah for Fox Cross Flex that's the cross
Flex yeah what is the cross when you get
to AFC teams on a Fox broadcast it is a
rarity it is like seeing Halley's Comet
it's a big deal
Jets dolphins on Fox ladies and
gentlemen Wow that might be tough to
sell that one yeah it's color
he almost my colleague yeah but but are
the Jets screwing up the draft you think
so right like what's the best thing that
happens they go nine and seven in a wild
card and then what you still don have
your quarterback for the future you
still Josh McCown but it's been so fun
to watch the Jets and they're so young
and they're so energetic and they don't
know any better I spoke with Jamal Adams
I've spoken with Jordan Jenkins Lyman
they think they're a playoff team like
they believe it and you know what this
season
why not why not I just saw this McLovin
sent it to me yeah the odds-on favorite
for the MVP okay is yes Alex Smith
second on the list
Kareem hunt Kareem hunt not on the list
Tom Brady third trying to think of an in
it tell me it's Carson wins it is is
just every team that is the best record
is now the back yeah that's why I hate
Power Rankings yes because if you lose
then you drop down Levin spot yeah then
you're like wait they're the Patriots
they lost a game they're still you know
there's still the best team so it's
Carson Wentz's the MVP yeah then Alex
Smith Tom Brady deshaun Watson fourth
and he leaves the NFL in touchdown
passes he's not even my Rookie of the
Year Leonard fournette my Rookie of the
Year oh man that's fine but that's a
quarterback yes no no no I think for net
or net is alright but it's better this
year than Zeke Elliot was last year he's
doing it with an offensive line that's
apart and no quarterback play for net is
unbelievable yeah well when you think
about it what they what their offense is
really predicated on is let's just run
the football and hopefully our
quarterback doesn't lose a game for us
and we have a great defense
yeah and hope that he gets a 90-yard run
at some point oh he did okay good yeah
so Russell Wilson is fifth on the list
Kirk Cousins Drew Brees and Matt Ryan
what what would you have any problem if
the Eagles win 10 or 11 games in Carson
Wentz win the MVP no no the team that
has the most I mean they're not gonna
win there won't be the number one seed
in the NFC of course ones having a
really nice season he's playing really
well it I don't know who the MVP needs
but it's week six it's October I don't
know what that's supposed to mean well
we try to hand out the Heisman now too
true and we do the first overall pick
before the college and Arnold's already
been given a jacket and has already been
put into Kenton and now they're saying
he might not even be the first
quarterback taken and he might not even
come back and looking at what he's doing
he probably shouldn't I mean I'm all for
go get yours when you want to go get it
but it feels like he needs a little more
seasoning there Josh Allen I think is
ready to play in the NFL he's not on a
good team but I think he's ready to play
Josh Rosen I have no idea what I'm
getting kind of like him you know it's
funny there's two guys that everyone in
the NFL talks to me about and says hey
you should watch this guy one is Luke
[ __ ] the kid up in Washington State I
mean I don't well he just had 507 say
like it he just had a game and five
interceptions get in the other one
Rudolph its Mason Rudolph at Oklahoma
State is this kid who just could throw
it all and then Baker Mayfield they say
well he's got a lot of Russel Wilson and
a lot of Colt McCoy and I'm gonna I'm
like is that Russell Wilson or in the
third round and Colt McCoy went late and
you know as an undersized guy who hasn't
had a real starting opportu is that a
compliment like he's the next well
that's I like Colt McCoy as a player
he's a very solid player and a great
college player but his Baker may feel
that or his Baker Mayfield the next Drew
Brees because I'm looking for next Drew
Brees in the first round I could see the
Drew Brees comparison and he does have
the chip on his shoulder Drew Brees
still has a chip on his shoulder at the
San Francisco Super Bowl Paulie got the
draft profile and Drew Brees I'd love to
see that now and we had him read it and
it talked about all of the negatives and
he was mad yeah oh yeah and he goes can
I have this I said yeah
because I I want to put this in my
locker I'm thinking you're at this stage
championship he still needs it you know
it's interesting because I did that game
last week the same
Lions game which was a crazy game and
and how he is the New Orleans Saints and
he's been so for so long
that everyone knows this but you know
the Dolphins had him in for a workout
and they look at his shoulder and say
nope it's not gonna work this is 2005
and they signed Dante Culpepper instead
and look at the two paths those
franchises have had since and now he is
New Orleans he's the greatest athlete
ever to play for the same but you had
Culpepper coming off major knee surgery
but they would Sabin still be with the
dolphins
that's amazing thing wait and imagine
the domino effect with that Peter who's
the who's the Alabama coach the last 15
you know it's like Saban gets fired he
gets blown out of there in Miami but if
and he swears to this day that he wanted
Drew Brees
he wanted Drew Brees but the trainer
swears he was it's true yeah I'm not
taking the Alabama job before that I
wasn't gonna leave Michigan State the
packers quarterbacking situation yeah
are they in good enough hands with Brett
Hundley so I've got sources in Green Bay
who all this summer when I would be
texting them what's the story like what
do I need to know I'm not making the
trick out there so tell me everyone said
it's Brett Hundley is playing really
well Brett Hundley sprained pretty well
I'm like that such an interesting thing
to focus on the backup quarterback who
are never gonna see there's nobody there
all like you'd understand how much he's
improved now he didn't look great last
week but I think with a week to prepare
going up against the Saints they might
be okay with Brett Hundley I don't know
if they're gonna win a Super Bowl with
Brett Hundley but they might be just
fine and in the NFC North try Biscay
still a work in progress
Stafford's all beat up the Lions didn't
look great last week and then you look
at the Vikings who gives you a better
chance to win Brett Hundley where
there's no tape on them and we don't
know what it could be
or Case Keenum who we know it is gonna
be and maybe Teddy Bridgewater coming
off an injury I think the Packers have
the best roster I think the Packers can
still win games it could still win the
NFC North with Brett Hundley
we know the LA Rams are watching Jared
Goff is watching the program so we have
to say something nice about gurgaon
Jared Goff looks the part he looks like
a first overall pick I need to see a
little more Jared this week were in
London playing in Arizona Cardinals
defense it's coming off bottling up
Jameis Winston let's see what this team
can do it's interesting what they did
they're playing in London in the last
two times they played in London they
they flew out right away and they lost
that game this week they're all staying
in Jacksonville for like five I've been
to
Jacksonville not sure what they're doing
on Wednesday and Thursday I think
they've been there since that hopefully
nothing hopefully nothing just watching
the Dan Patrick show yeah but we've
we've made that leap in the second year
we always look for that any player
including quarterback the improvement it
just feels like he knows what he has
confidence when he goes out there
because he has people an infrastructure
that have instilled confidence in him
well you've nailed it I mean look last
year was Jeff Fisher was a head coach
Rob Boras Chris Weinke there were some
nice guys and Jeff Garcia was there at
some point
but now McVeigh we've done the raving
about McNabb time at the other guys Matt
Lafleur you're talking about Greg Olson
who was on fence according this league
for a million years and you've got other
minds in that room that are really
helping him develop and every one to a
man says the same thing McVeigh and
cousins spoke to saying that same
language him and Goff aren't even
scratching the surface yet it's only you
know room for improvement is incredible
in the foreign to he's Peter Schrager
NFL Network and Fox Sports is on Good
Morning football you can see that Monday
through Friday at 7:00 a.m. Eastern and
then he's got the Colts and the Jets
this weekend Thursday Night Football is
on the NFL Network and CBS Chiefs and
the Raiders the Colts are a mess right
now we don't I don't know if you get to
a point where you say let's not bring
Andrew Luck back if you get to nine
games you can bring him back now because
you're still in the race but I just
don't know what he's coming back to when
he comes back the intriguing thing about
it is that everyone is three and three
and they're two and four and they're
somehow still in the thick of it they're
gonna be in the thick of this come
December so if he does want to come in
and play this heroes role and say hey
you know what throw it on my back let's
go but I was there two weeks ago and he
wasn't thrown the football great
distances he wasn't doing live action
per set is coming along you know my
co-host on the good morning football
show Kyle brain compared it to blue
harvest which is the Star Wars what they
would call when they were filming Return
of the Jedi they don't want anyone
around so there was all this secrecy
around it they just called it blue
harvest and no one can see what's going
that's what it feels like with Andrew
Luck we're seeing him in these glimpses
on the sidelines but you're seeing it at
practice and he he might not be able to
throw a football ten times in a game or
he might be close to being back they are
so secretive about this that there's
this intriguing piece to the Colts that
yeah they don't look good but just hang
in the thick of this hang a game back
hang two games
back he could still save the season did
you think Tony Romo at least entertained
the idea of if the Packers call I think
in the offseason it probably was but
he's having such a success right now and
he's doing he seems to be loving it now
you find me week 13 when he's at the
Cincinnati Sheraton on a Thursday and
then he's at the Jacksonville
you know Hyatt Place or whatever it's
called let's see where he's at if he
wants to come back but I think right now
he loves what he's doing it passion
seems and I don't think he's in playing
shape I don't think he gives him a
better chance to win them right humbly
right now what do you think yeah III
think his body was in there three years
yes but guys are the last to know when
it's time to go
I hope Tony knows that you know your
body didn't help you when you were sort
of healthy with the Cowboys and now
you're gonna go back and he's got a
great job though the NFL could use it
yeah you could when you lose JJ whattodo
and Aaron Rodgers a Tony Romo comeback
sad the Adrian Peterson story is
welcomed in my eyes yeah give me a star
that I know and I can love should
Beckham be the highest-paid player in
the game now he's not a quarterback
I am so pro quarterback I can't these
teams that have great Aaron Donald he's
probably watching great player they were
four and twelve with him on the field
last year a quarterback changes the team
a quarterback is the face of the league
and a face of the team so no Odell
Beckham should not be the highest-paid
player yeah I know Von Miller came out
and kind of coached nice afoot Beckham
yeah but I don't see I can take Beckham
out of a game yes any you know there's
so much that goes with him now from
marketing Millennials like you you tap
into a whole different audience with him
that no other player rocks them yeah
they come close you compare him to Kanye
West you don't know what's going on
inside that head Boeing the when the
game starts this guy's unbelievable well
then who's jay-z who's jay-z that'd be
Tom Brady the greatest to ever do it
yeah we can go deep we can go deep
tracks if you want do you think jay-z is
a better rapper than Tupac do you think
do you think Brady's a better
quarterback than Montana yes okay yeah
because I think L ways better than
Montana yeah well no I said Joe I told
you that III would take John Elway I
think Elway is the best who ever played
the position yes I thought he did more
with less
went to the three Super Bowls got blown
out then he finally had a little help
and then they win a couple of Super
Bowls here's one for you
final drive of the game minute left
you're on your own twenty would you
rather have Aaron Rodgers in his prime
or John Elway in his prime Elway oh yeah
love this debate yeah Elway well I saw
it I know I saw it
Rodgers hasn't done it in the tsukina
playoff in the play yeah the last year
against Dallas that was a great play
that was Elway esque
oh yeah but look at what Elway did
against Houston look at what he did
against the Browns multiple times yes I
mean that's just that that's reaching in
five to ten stands out to me too though
well we realized that they didn't they
had the Orange Crush defense and they
were who was it Tony Lilly was either
free safe yeah they just burned him but
that's not necessarily on all on Elway
that I like how we give him credit to
get to the Super Bowl and then we're
gonna blame it happen in the Super Bowl
let's see well three to three times with
some pretty subpar rest around him I
know but then you're trying to compare
generations and that's where it's always
tough with if I have somebody now and I
have Joe Montana how would Joe Montana
be if you can't touch his wide receivers
I'm running that often how would Steve
young beingness Steve Young would be
better I think than Joe because you know
the elusiveness of him he's you know he
completed 70% of the past and he avoids
some of those injuries yeah and we are
finding that and I think this is the
hardest part is finding offensive
linemen now in college football and you
see these quarterbacks are getting hit
more and more than it feels like we
we've had in recent years why is that
we just had an NFL Draft where Garrett
Bowles was the first offensive lineman
taken he was taken in the mid 20
somewhere it they're they're not in
there because they're spread offenses
and these guys that are growing up
they're playing seven on seven you don't
get a Walter Jones walking through the
door anymore and the the the success
rate of these guys Luke djoko's had a
nice little career I Derek Fisher is
okay but you look at Greg Robinson and
some of these other guys the top five
picks out offensive tackle has not been
great in recent years Peter Schreyer
it's always great to have you in studio
Pete doing great work
good morning football that's Monday
through Friday at 7:00 a.m. Eastern
now you said you carry the show
basically on your back oh it's it hurt I
feel a lot like sometimes I feel like
Aaron Raj
out there and you said that the people
you work with aren't that knowledgeable
not that knowledgeable not that smart
not that good-looking are you trying to
leave yeah no this is my you want your
own show
this is my Kevin Durant no no like
hinting no we're not the Warriors feet I
like it you're welcome to come here cool
no I love good morning people I think
you'd like it too oh no it's too early
to know who would we trade to the oh no
good one acquire Peter yeah I'd be a
conditional six round pick
Peter's got a lot of years left in the
tank yeah you know not too old not too
young
yeah here's good yeah it's good Andrew
and Abby are G to be named later
McLovin in a backroom guy how about
McLovin in our IT guy Alan whoa it also
does all the grilling on the trigger
grill yeah yeah yeah yes my god they
said the show would fall apart in three
days without the IT guy oh yeah I don't
see it maybe me and Peter have nothing
no similarities what's know nothing yeah
place him with me and the best person oh
I like how people say you know hey which
why don't you hire me or I would have
done that and at the time I couldn't get
anybody to do the good-morning football
show I'm waking up at 3:30 in the
morning every day and everyone's like oh
that's it that's a great show I wish I
why don't we do one day trade and we
don't tell anybody Schrager shows up
here he sits right Andrew seats Andrew
goes over to good morning football just
walks in with one of shraeger
you know a long-sleeve shirts and there
we go I would love it the Trager grill I
can do the Schrager grill
that's his new segment what do you what
he has it's sort of against the grain
but it's Schrager grill where he won and
done yeah would you be willing to I'm
not because he's gonna be awesome in my
position making me look awful from that
on and I'm gonna be terrible or anything
good all right let's see if we can do
that trade straight up carson wentz for
MVP go make that case thank you page
save travels with so much the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience